bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce 4 décembre
pour une nouvelle édition du Journal de
la rédaction une journal de la rédaction
que nous consacrerons en très grande
partie ce soir au Téléthon coup d'envoi
prévu pour demain vendredi mobilisation
à travers la France afin de récolter des
fonds pour la recherche et enfin guérir
des maladies longtemps considérées comme
incurable nous verrons comment se
prépare les bénévoles le programme
également composé dans plusieurs villes
des Yvelines une rue change de nom à
Saint-Cyr-l'École et c'est tout un
quartier qui se mobilise la rue Dimitrov
22 venir rue Mandela le conseil
municipal a été agité mercredi soir
manifestation d'une quarantaine de
personnes le maire de Coignières l'a dit
est répété il ne veut pas de nouvelles
frontières à son intercommunalité alors
que l'État pourrait lui imposer de se
rapprocher par exemple de 50 ans en
Yvelines il a décidé de donner la parole
aux habitants à un référendum est prévu
ce weekend
et puis dans l'actualité du jour
également cette réunion à La Verrière ou
un nouveau collectif a été mis en place
un collectif pour le renouveau citoyen
une centaine d'habitants qui a signé un
appel pour exprimer leur déception
vis-à-vis de la politique actuelle entre
autres il rencontre en ce moment même
dans la salle du scarabée des
responsable nationaux des parties de
gauche Benoît monte Catherine taska pour
le PS ou encore Emmanuel Causse pour
Europe Écologie Les Verts ainsi que
Laurence Cohen pour le Front de gauche
une soirée de débat que le maire de la
commune Alain âge souhaite porteuse de
nouvelles perspectives pour la majorité
actuelle aux affaires en France les
détails dans nos tradition de demain
vendredi
à Saint-Cyr-l'École le conseil municipal
a voté le changement de nom de la rue
Dimitrov elle s'appellera dorénavant rue
Nelson Mandela un changement de nom qui
n'est pas du goût des riverains ils ont
essayé de se faire entendre hier soir
avant la tenue du conseil municipal
Mélanie poquet et William L
le sujet de la discorde c'est cette rue
située à quelque part de la mairie de
Saint-Cyr-l'École Georges Dimitrov était
un militant communiste mort en 1949 la
mairie veut modifier le nom de l'artère
alors hier soir une dizaine de riverains
espèrent encore faire changer d'avis
Monsieur le Maire une pétition a
recueilli 44 signatures sur les 62
résidents concernés le souci qu'il y a
c'est surtout pas d'ordre politique pour
nous c'est un ordre administratif
notamment tous les changements qu'il y
aura à faire qui coûtent qui ont un coût
et qui en plus pose des désagréments
surtout au commerce qui doivent changer
par exemple leur statut et ça coûte très
cher l'idée du changement de nom avait
été lancée par un élu communiste mais la
Rudy mitrophe n'était pas celle
concernée ce qu'a fait mon ancien
colistier Jean-Yves Maximilien s'est
proposé le nom de Nelson Mandela pour
une autre place de Saint-Cyr en lieu et
place de Madame de Maintenon du côté de
la mairie le choix de cette rue
s'explique par le passé de Georges dim
itrov
ce monsieur grand ami de Staline membre
du comité était surnommé le boucher
bulgare puisque c'était lui qui avait
installé le Parti communiste en Bulgarie
je pensais qu'il n'avait pas son sa
place à Saint-Cyr la mairie a envoyé
aux reptait le changement de nom la
mairie prendra en charge les fraisiers
au formalités de changement la rue
Dimitrov elle deviendra prochainement la
rune Nelson Mandela la future plaque
comportera la mention ancienne rue
dimitrophe
le maire de Coignières qui lance une
consultation populaire ce dimanche il
souhaite demander à ses administrés s'il
souhaite eux oui ou non un élargissement
de la communauté de communes à laquelle
ils appartiennent une sorte de
référendum qui sera transmis ensuite au
préfet de région alors que ce dernier a
d'ores et déjà présenté son propre
projet d'intercommunalité à plus de
800.000 habitants Catherine zulato
William elle
le maire de Coignières veut protéger son
intercommunalité la ville fait partie de
la communauté de communes des étangs
forte de 38 000 habitants comprenant
Maurepas les bréviaires Les
Essarts-le-Roi et le paierai en Yvelines
pas question d'y toucher alors que le
préfet de région a présenté lui un
projet d'intercommunalité à 800000
habitants je suis dans une communauté de
communauté humaine où les élus sont pas
encore trop éloignés on va dire de la
vie d'isserait et donc à partir de là et
bien c'est une cohésite commune donc il
y a une dimension qui me convient
parfaitement la comité d'agglomération
qu'on nous propose nous imposera tout
sur le plan financier non parlons pas je
sais pas l'expérience que dès l'instant
où les structures sont énormes ou sont
grosses les impôts locaux augmentent en
septembre dernier un collectif s'est
créé pour défendre la Communauté de
Communes des étangs une défense qui
passe par une consultation populaire ce
dimanche les Coignières sont appelés aux
urnes pour voter oui ou non à cette
question souhaitez-vous la préservation
de la Communauté de Communes des étangs
dans son périmètre actuel je souhaite et
je veux que
c'est ce que j'espère que la progression
répondent devant ce mois-ci à cette
habitation d'une part parce que c'est
important pour la survie de poignet on
est en démocratie et je pense également
et je pense donc que mes administrés ont
le droit de leur avis je dirais sur une
affaire qui va complètement bouleverser
leur existence
deux bureaux de vote seront ouverts l'un
en mairie l'autre à l'école Bouvet les
résultats de la consultation seront
transmis au préfet de région sa décision
concernant l'intercommunalité élargite
devrait être rendue en février 2015 et
dès ce vendredi soir la mairie de
Coignières organise une réunion publique
d'information
le Téléthon 30 heures d'émission sur le
service public au profit de la recherche
sur les maladies génétiques
neuromusculaires et sur les maladies
génétiques rares depuis 1987 les fonds
sont collectés par l'Association
Française contre les Myopathies la FM
mais lorsque vous faites un don
savez-vous comment utiliser concrètement
cet argent ce spot va vous donner
quelques indications
en 2015 l'AFM Téléthon s'engage pour 100
euros données
8 euros seront utilisés pour ces frais
de gestion
12 euros pour ses frais de collecte
54 euros pour la recherche
24 euros pour aider les malades
et 2 euros pour l'information
scientifique médicale et sociale c'est
donc 80 euros qui seront dédiés au
combat contre la maladie pour en savoir
plus appelé la ligne directe donateurs
connectez-vous sur téléthon.fr
moi aussi je donne moi aussi je donne
moi aussi je donne
voici donnez
merci
et pour collecter c'est donc pour animer
les villes pendant ces 30 heures de
Téléthon qui débute demain les bénévoles
je reçois en plateau Daniel Bazan
coordinateur départemental du Téléthon
bienvenue sur ce plateau bienvenue
également à Daniel Tamam bonsoir
président d'objectif Téléthon manigois à
manier les hameaux et également en
plateau Christophe parent bonsoir vous
êtes trésorier pour le Téléthon aux
Clayes-sous-Bois il devrait nous
rejoindre dans un instant le Maire
Adjoint délégué au sport à la ville de
plaisir pour parler là aussi de
l'engagement de cette commune sur le
Téléthon comment s'annonce cette édition
du Téléthon dans les Yvelines aura-t-on
une forte mobilisation est-ce qu'il y
aura de nombreux rendez-vous ben on
l'espère du moins il y a beaucoup de
nouvelles manifestations donc c'est déjà
un point rendement
organisées au total au total sur les
Yvelines on a 96 enfin
105 contrats à l'heure actuelle de
rentrer donc ça veut dire 87 communes à
peu près sur 102 communes que je gère au
niveau de
à la ville de plaisir on va parler avec
vous aussi également du Téléthon et nos
autres invités ce soir d'année en année
la mobilisation reste maintient est
stable le nom de bénévoles également
même l'engagement le nombre de bénévoles
je vais dire qu'il en augmentation j'ai
19 personnes à la coordination quand je
l'ai pris en 2007 on était 6 donc on a
et cette année j'ai beaucoup recruté
donc on a beaucoup de nouveaux
départements de bonne élève au niveau
national de manifestations vous êtes
assez fier de ce qui est organisé tout à
fait
sur ce Téléthon on dit chaque année mais
forcément vous êtes toujours présent
mobilisé pour venir nous parler de des
actions que vous menez comment s'annonce
le Téléthon chez vous relativement bien
tout le monde est sur le pont c'est très
c'est très chaud
je pense qu'on va assurer un peu plus de
30 heures d'activités
qui sont en train de travailler oui pour
métamorphoser notamment de gymnase dans
lequel nous avons donné une coloration
l'année dernière combien vous avez
réussi à collecter sur la ville de manie
environ 28000 euros et au niveau des
départementales
j'étais un petit peu en baisse vu
2002-2012 j'avais fait
426000 euros et 417 l'année dernière et
je pense cette année repasser la barre
des 400 arrivées au 500 j'espère
puisqu'on parle un petit peu d'argent
est-ce que les gens qui viennent sur les
manifestations du Téléthon j'ai posé la
question à Christophe parent vous
demande à quoi sert cet argent où est-ce
qu'ils viennent spontanément et ils font
une confiance aveugle on a les
trésoriens on a les les deux profils on
a des certaines personnes qui viennent
qui se renseignent parce que c'est vrai
qu'on entend un petit peu tout et
n'importe quoi sur internet à la télé un
petit peu donc il y a pas mal de
boulimie comme tous les tous les ans
donc nous on est là pour rassurer pour
leur expliquer donc justement le petit
spot que vous avez passé bon on a des
documents pour leur faire voir
exactement à quoi sert cet argent nous
avons également en plus nous essayons
d'avoir sur place des des bénéficiaires
en fait de de de ses dons par le biais
de donc de de personnes qui sont
atteintes de myopathie ou de d'autres
maladies qui sont traitées grâce au
Téléthon donc ils peuvent expliquer
également et on va leur dire voyez dans
mon cas ça m'aide aussi donc ça rassure
aussi les gens ce n'est pas simplement
de la de l'argent qui est donné et qui a
fond perdu on sait pas où il va on voit
on essaie de leur savoir du concret un
maximum et ça sachant qu'ils peuvent
aussi se rapprocher de des différents
coordinations maintenant on a aussi le
Généthon pas mal de choses qui existent
donc ils peuvent voir du concret des des
avancées Généthon qui ouvre assez
souvent un ses portes d'ailleurs pour
montrer la presse et communique très
largement sur le travail qui est mené on
verra des images tout à l'heure encore
Généthon qui qui ouvre donc ces portes
chaque année et qui permet de mener ces
recherches ça c'est pour la partition
scientifique vraiment le travail des
médecins de votre côté on n'est pas sur
ce registre là on est sur l'amusement il
faut occuper les gens sur Les
Clayes-sous-Bois vous proposez quoi
cette année alors cette année nous avons
on a changé un petit peu le le
système habituellement nous avions le
parti de vendredi soir les les sports
traditionnellement qu'ils étaient pas
mal de démonstration pour attirer du
monde et puis en même temps récolter un
maximum de fonds et le plus un côté
ludique on va dire le samedi cette année
nous avons fait ce côté ludique sur les
du vendredi au samedi soir et les sports
et autres sont répartis au long des deux
jours donc on va avoir le vendredi soir
par exemple une une grande soirée avec
des des groupes locaux de danse on a
accordé MJC et autres qui vont faire on
a également si one un chanteur qui va
qui va faire une prestation vendredi
soir donc un grand moment festif le
samedi dans la dans la journée nous
aurons donc démonstration sportive
différentes activités on a également une
bourse aux jouets des choses comme ça
pour finir le samedi soir
par des démonstrations de plaquettes
irlandaises et un grand fest-noz alors
tout ça est très équilibré on le voit
que c'est au millimètre
on est également similaire pendant une
trentaine d'heures nous allons alterner
en concurrence
pour la même cause
au même endroit c'est pour les malades
danse
chant concert et un fil rouge pendant
toute la durée du Téléthon toujours des
personnalités qui viennent à Manille il
y en aura cette année il y aura
effectivement une personnalité qui cette
année Alexis Thibault qui est animateur
radio qui sera présent chaque année vous
voulez faire l'événement sur
Magny-les-Hameaux vous avez toujours à
faire venir des personnalités des people
un petit peu pour attirer les gens c'est
ouvert
d'être partout mais ce sera encore
difficile pour pour les équipes de
téléfilm de couvrir l'ensemble des
manifestations vous l'avez dit il y en a
encore beaucoup cette année vous voyez
ce que ce soit un petit peu homogène et
que tout le monde se retrouve en fait ah
oui non mais quel est votre rôle en tant
que coordinateur départemental
d'importer un petit pain soutien et puis
si les organisateurs ont besoin de
renseignements tout ça ben on est là on
est des intermédiaires des débris quoi
du côté des comme des communes des
villes comment on s'organise on voit les
bénévoles sont très mobilisés les
municipalités à plaisir par exemple
comment vous avez travaillé sur cette
édition du Téléthon alors pour nous
c'est un peu une nouveauté puisque on
avait fait on avait vu cette expérience
il y a quelques années une bonne dizaine
d'années et là on a voulu vraiment se
relancer sur un téléthon alors c'est un
une version un petit peu nouvelle elle
sera un peu plus courte dans le temps
dans la durée c'est-à-dire qu'on
commence à 19h et on finira à 22h30 il y
a un fil rouge alors qui est une Zumba
géante donc c'est sous l'égide de la
direction de l'espoir évidemment et on a
une association
sportive qui est la gymnastique
volontaire et qui va encadrer cette
hommage géante alors moi j'ai été très
très surpris de très étonné je dirais
même de voir le nombre de personnes le
nombre de de volontaires et de demande
pour participer justement au Téléthon
alors on a même été obligé de refuser
enfin de refuser oui certaines
es de malheureusement alors
mais c'est vraiment il y a vraiment un
enthousiasme derrière et je pense que
c'est sur l'ensemble des communes
personnelles à disposition
donc cette zone là géante sera si vous
voulez encadrer par le cette association
sportive mais c'est la direction des
sports qui émettent d'oeuvre si je puis
dire qui a coordonné l'ensemble des de
l'organisation avec les différentes
directions de la ville avec les
différents donateurs parce qu'il a fallu
rechercher aussi bien sûr des des
partenaires ce qu'il faudrait
bien s'amuser mais il faut quand même
penser à la recherche et donc le
personnel de la ville est très impliqué
dans dans cette dans cette organisation
et dans cette édition on va écouter à
présent une autre élu elle est en charge
du Téléthon intercommunal entre
Bois-d'Arcy Saint-Cyr-l'École
Fontenay-le-Fleury ce sera à la ferme de
la trembler à Bois-d'Arcy une quinzaine
de bénévoles mobilisés au moins 25
associations présentes on écoute Marilyn
Rolland elle espère collecter au moins
4000 euros
nous avons prévu tout un site au bar de
la tremblais pour organiser des
rendez-vous associatifs donc de danse
d'aïkido différentes associations des
trois communes qui vont se produire à
partir de vendredi soir 18h puisque je
crois que le lancement du Téléthon se
fait par l'AFM vendredi à 18h donc
Bois-d'Arcy s'adaptera aussi aux mêmes
horaires et toute la journée de samedi
alors il va y avoir également le marché
de Noël qui aura lieu à la salle des
fêtes de La Tremblaye donc on a jugé que
le Téléthon avait toute sa place dans ce
cadre-là pour que les arcisiens et les
autres personnes du canton puissent
venir découvrir les associations il y a
au moins 25 associations qui seront
présentes alors présente officiellement
le jour du Téléthon bien sûr mais il ne
faut pas oublier toutes les associations
qui ont souhaité y participer d'une
manière indirecte et qui lors de leurs
activités au ou dans les autres communes
d'ailleurs je pense tout
particulièrement aussi au lycée Mansart
qui va participer ainsi que quelques
écoles de Saint-Cyr bénévoles sont prêts
pour le Téléthon qui va donc débuter
demain pendant que nous écoutions cette
petite vidéo vous me disiez que le
Téléthon s'annonçait plutôt bien il y a
déjà eu des événements qui ont été
organisés dans le département le weekend
dernier ou anticipé et ça c'est très
bien passé très bien les chiffres sont
roses donc les deux j'espère que ça va
continuer mais bon j'ai chez soi
qui vient de sortir écrit par Serge
Braun directeur scientifique de l'AFM
Téléthon son titre comme un hommage
assez bénévole on peut changer le monde
en vendant des crêpes et des ballons
est-ce que c'est votre sentiment
justement ce que vous avez le sentiment
de changer le monde est-ce que vous le
vous le faites pour ça mais en tout cas
est-ce que vous avez vous en tirez une
fierté aussi chacun des bénévoles
engagés
je sens le conflit non non pas du tout
parce qu'il est très intéressant c'est
que le fait le Téléthon va fédérer et
que tout le monde est concerné et comme
tout le monde est concerné et il y a une
mobilisation générale effectivement en
vendant des crêpes en faisant une
démonstration sportive en venant faire
un concert là là il y a quelque chose de
d'extraordinaire il se passe quelque
chose et vous y pensez justement lorsque
vous organisez tout ça vous vous dites
voilà je suis mobilisé je vais passer 30
heures sur le terrain ça va servir à
quelque chose oui tout à fait toute
façon quand on s'engage c'est avec mon
bénévolat mais ça fait pas mal d'années
depuis 92 que dans le bénévolat donc
différents bénévolat mais quand on
rentre dans du bénévolat soit pour une
cause comme ça ou pour un simple club
sportif on rentre dedans mais en disant
je vais servir à quelque chose c'est sûr
que si on ne voyait pas de positif
derrière on n'aurait pas tous moins de
là qui nous nous suivrait et nous ça
nous pousse encore plus voir que ben il
y a tous tous ces ételan ça nous ça nous
booste encore plus ça nous donne envie
d'aller encore plus loin et ce sera la
journée mondiale du bénévolat d'ailleurs
demain vendredi et ce sera le jour du
lancement du Téléthon ce sera un beau
clin d'oeil et vous le disiez un plaisir
vous refusez du monde il y a de plus en
plus de bénévoles tout le monde
s'implique les associations c'est
quelque chose de très dynamique alors on
a reçu beaucoup de propositions de la
part d'association qu'elle soit
culturelle sportive ou autre et bon
comme on était déjà bien avancé dans
l'organisation c'est toujours difficile
de raccrocher un petit peu d'autres
éléments à une organisation qu'on essaie
l'année prochaine voilà ils sont déjà
fait pour l'année prochaine ça sera une
bonne expérience depuis tout à l'heure
vous prenez des notes sur les prix sur
les engagements de chacun
mais comme vous le disiez effectivement
nous on impulse ce mouvement par par la
volonté d'organiser justement cet
événement mais sur la ville mais aussi
ben on se sent porté par le flot de tous
ces de tous ces volontaires de tout cet
enthousiasme en fait et c'est volontaire
c'est bénévoles on va aller retrouver
dès à présent on part pour maniller les
mots justement rencontre sur le terrain
dernier préparatif avant le jour J dans
les locaux de l'association Objectif
Téléthon manicois on se prépare pour le
grand rendez-vous de l'année et là on
met le vélo rouge et ce sera un gros lot
à l'occasion du Téléthon l'association
va tenter de récolter un maximum de dons
au profit de l'Association Française
contre les myopathie Patricia 67 ans à
la retraite est engagé ici depuis 5 ans
c'est venu comme ça avec le temps avec
les relations en fait on a des amis qui
sont dans des associations qui ont
besoin qui demandent de l'aide une fois
deux fois trois fois on voit ce que
c'est et puis et puis on rentre dans
l'association
avec la vingtaine de bénévoles devenus
pour certains des amis elle prépare les
30 heures de l'événement depuis le mois
d'octobre ça permet de rester en contact
avec des gens actuellement je suis à la
retraite et sans ça je m'ennuierai chez
moi
l'avantage c'est justement de d'avoir
l'impression d'être encore utile à
quelque chose
faire appel aux associations aux
commerçants et entreprises de la ville
pour récolter des dons préparer les
décors la loterie ou encore la
restauration autant de missions qui
demandent du temps et plus de bénévoles
on en manque c'est vrai que ça repose
beaucoup sur les mêmes personnes bon je
comprends très bien que les gens qui
travaillent c'est pas évident
même si on fait des soirées des soirées
bénévoles et des soirées de travail bon
on arrive à avoir des jeunes mais on
manque de bénévoles c'est sûr c'est sûr
qu'il en faudrait plus
plus de 1000 euros ont été récoltés pour
cette édition 2014 l'année dernière la
ville de Magny avait récolté 27000 euros
environ 20 000 euros sur place et 7000
euros en promesse de dons sur internet
ils espèrent faire encore mieux cette
année
mais vous êtes d'accord
pas de spécial Téléthon dans ce journal
dans cette édition et vous allez écouter
à présent comme les téléspectateurs de
notre question du jour notre
micro-trottoir avec vous le sentiment
que la recherche avance le Téléthon
existe depuis 1987 parce que les choses
ont changé est-ce votre sentiment voici
quelques réponses
j'espère que ça avance parce que avec
l'argent qui a récolté quand même
faudrait que ça avance j'ai pas vraiment
que l'impression les choses ont changé
et j'ai pas vraiment l'impression que le
Téléthon fasse vraiment
bouger la recherche je vois pas de
traçabilité des fonds on voit pas la
sortie au niveau de la recherche
ça avance uniquement quand on en parle
si on en parle pas ça avance pas je
pense oui avec les dons qui sont donnés
par les la population
oui je pense oui moi non parce que
effectivement chaque année des fonds
sont collectés maintenant ce qui se fait
avec les fonds j'ai l'impression que ça
stagne un petit peu on n'est pas bien
informé sur la recherche et son avancée
notamment donc c'est un petit peu
dommage quand même c'est étrange le
sentiment parce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure que le Généthon là où la
recherche se passe ouvrer ses portes que
le Téléthon communiquait beaucoup sur
l'utilisation de l'argent le sentiment
que ça avance pas est-ce que ça avance
la recherche tout à fait c'est un vent
parce que là on est déjà sur les
la maladie de du chêne où on a déjà
détecté le rennement le médicament qu'il
fallait et qui va être sur le marché
dans les années à venir donc la
recherche avance tout à fait tout à fait
aujourd'hui 36 essais cliniques qui qui
sont en qui sont en cours et certains
essais ont apporté des résolutions la
les résolutions génétiques c'est
l'avenir bien sûr que ça avance il faut
y croire peut-être qu'on communique pas
suffisamment toute l'année mais il y a
une communication malgré tout qui est
faite et les malades l'attente cette
recherche on va partir à présent à la
rencontre de Malik masse Maes de son nom
d'artistique il est rappeur il a 30 ans
il habite à Trappes atteint d'une
rétinite pigmentaire il a commencé à
perdre la vue dès l'âge de 16 ans c'est
son fils de 6 ans qui lui redonne chaque
jour l'espoir
j'attends de la rétinite pigmentaire
donc je perds progressivement la vue on
admettant que un cercle représente ma
vision la vision normale de tout le
monde on met un fer à cheval à
l'intérieur de ce cercle là et le fer à
cheval c'est ma vision donc
personnellement je la ressens pas comme
ça mais avec les tests que j'ai fait
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui montre ce que
mes yeux voient et là ces derniers temps
je pense avoir perdu encore un peu de
champ visuel parce que là j'ai
l'impression que le matin comme
l'après-midi ou comme le soir j'ai
l'impression qu'il fait toujours son
quoi
donc voilà et après il y a d'autres
d'autres petits facteurs par exemple
j'arrive à lire encore les gros titres
il y a peu de temps et là avec mon œil
gauche par exemple je n'ai plus du tout
il y a pas mal de choses qu'on peut plus
faire donc ça demande une autre
logistique le fait déjà de plus compte
de plus conduire ça veut dire soit
dépendre des autres ou se débrouiller à
pied donc ça va j'ai de la chance je
fais pas mal de choses sur la ville mais
voilà ça demande une autre logistique
une autre préparation et
pour ce qui s'ensuit c'est à dire la vie
quotidienne c'est pareil aussi pas mal
de petits subterfuge à mettre en place
par exemple dans le choix des vêtements
ou voilà je quand je prends mes
vêtements aujourd'hui au toucher j'ai un
autre repère pour les
hormis les mains je sais que j'utilise
mes lèvres en fait comme si une partie
plus sensible je reconnais facilement
les matières de mes vêtements avec avec
mes lèvres dans le pire des cas ça
évolue vers la cécité après on a
toujours dit les médecins m'ont toujours
dit que il était possible que par
exemple la vision que j'avais à l'époque
je pouvais la garder à vie ou elle
pouvait évoluer sur cinq ans cinq ans
c'était le minimum qui m'avait dit à
l'époque et on est au 5 ans par rapport
à notre notre gêne à nous il y a des
recherches quand même dessus mais
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
trouvailles
oui ça je suis obligé on est obligé
d'être optimiste ça c'est je dis
toujours c'est une épreuve si on la
pollution la poser sur les épaules c'est
que je pouvais la porter donc faut que
j'apporte j'ai pas le choix de toute
façon il ne resterait pas de temps pour
conclure cette édition on portrait
complet de Malik mas dans le prochain
numéro de check-up entretien mené par
Yolaine Torres juste les malades sont
présents et s'impliquent en deux mots
très brièvement sur chacun de vos
événements ils sont présents
ils sont présents sur toutes les
communes manies les clés ou encore
plaisir pour le Téléthon on n'oublie pas
aussi toutes les autres communes on
essaiera à t'y venir je sais que vous
allez me le demander dès que cette
émission sera terminée merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup à tous les quatre d'être
venu en plateau toutes les informations
36 37 pour donner internet également
tout de suite sur tvfils c'est filco
magazine économique l'info écho avec
Florian parfait